en tout cas il faut évidemment réformer
ce code du travail plus que la réforme
elles refont des comme on dit
aujourd'hui ça veut dire quoi refonder
ça veut dire et à écrire ça veut dire
revenir année l'adapter réécrire et ne
pas évidemment commencer à rayer 3 3
bouts de phrases retirer une page
remettre une autre tout ça ne fonctionne
pas et c'est ce que nous avons indiqué
lors de la première table ronde avec
vraiment l'idée d'une partie qui est une
partie plus législatives normative qui
s'impose à tous
et puis évidemment une partie qui
renvoie aux accords d'entreprises non
pas par dérogation mais qui renvoie aux
accords d'entreprise par liberté je je
je voudrais maintenant qu'on puisse
entendre
annie genevard il ya beaucoup de qualité
mais qui a aussi la qualité d'avoir
d'avoir travaillé sur le sur le rsi
c'est un des irritants comme on dit
aujourd'hui assez fort de la société
française est évidemment tous nos amis
qui exercent un travail indépendant
souffre beaucoup du régime social qui
leur est aujourd'hui imposé il ne
fonctionne pas et il ne fonctionne pas
marche pas et donc ça complique leur
travail et donc ça est un frein au
travail indépendant et voilà merci annie
de nous en dire plus merci eric bonjour
à tous
alors comme tu l'as dit eric c'est un
sujet majeur et si vous interrogez vos
commerçants vos artisans les
indépendants qui sont autour de vous et
qui sont partout sur le territoire
national
vous prononcer ces trois lettres c'est
magique ça suscite dans la seconde à
niveau d'exaspération maximale alors je
dis ça sur un ton qui n'est pas léger
parce que nous avons véritablement à
faire à des situations qui peuvent se
révéler absolument dramatique sur le
plan économique sur le plan humain et
personnel j'ai animé la semaine dernière
dans ma commune une réunion sur le rsi
j'ai été extrêmement surprise il fallait
pas mal de doigté pour conduire cette
réunion julien aubert notre ami député
du vaucluse l'a fait avec beaucoup de
beaucoup de talent parce qu' il fallait
que ça sorte
il fallait que les gens s'expriment et
en même temps il fallait parvenir à
canaliser tout 7,7 cette colère qui lie
à chez les indépendants aujourd'hui et
le simple fait qu'on leur donne la
parole à était déjà positif parce que ça
leur a permis
ils ont eu le sentiment que il ne se
débattait pas sans que nous soyons
conscients des difficultés qu'ils
éprouvent nous avons une immense
responsabilité sur cette question et
récits parce que après le régime général
c'est le second régime de protection
sociale en france cela concerne six
millions de ressortissants et presque 3
millions de cotisants ça concerne
l'ensemble du territoire national des
indépendants il a partout dans le plus
petit village de france vous avez un
indépendant et ça concerne tous les
secteurs de la vie économique
les indépendants du secteur industriel
du secteur commercial du secteur
artisanal du secteur libéral
par conséquent c'est viral quand vous
avez un problème sur une protection
sociale qui concerne un territoire aussi
vaste des domaines d'activités aussi
nombreux et une population aussi
importante
on a vraiment une impérieuse obligation
de se pencher sur la question et elle
est d'autant plus impérieuse cette
obligation que l'air et si c'est nous
qui l'avons mis en place nous l'avons
mis en place parce que les indépendants
demandent un interlocuteur unique
nous avons travaillé avec eux nous avons
mis en place par mesure de
simplification
cet interlocuteur social unique par la
fusion de trois caisses alors qu'est ce
qui s'est passé pourquoi en sommes-nous
arrivés là
et bien parce que comme toujours
si l'idée est bonne mais que la mise en
oeuvre n'est pas maîtrisée et bien la
meilleure des idées non seulement se
perd mais elle devient contre productive
elle se retourne contre ses initiateurs
et c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
devons pour la reconquête nous
intéresser au moins autant au projet
qu'à la façon de le mettre en oeuvre
la méthode de mise en oeuvre sera
quelque chose de déterminant alors ce
qui s'est passé et bien tout simplement
c'est une mise en oeuvre compliquée avec
une politique de sous-traitance massive
les commerçants qui vous disent quand
j'appelle le verrai si je tombe à
l'étranger quelqu'un qui n'est pas au
courant
une politique de sous-traitance massive
des outils informatiques inadaptée aussi
bête que ça puisse paraître les outils
informatiques sont inadaptées et
commettent des erreurs
et puis la complexité d'organisation ce
qui en 2012 avait fait dire à la cour
des comptes qu'il fallait absolument
réformer le système
faute de quoi on mettait en péril le
système même d'assurance maladie et de
retraite des indépendants
donc oui le danger il est il est mortel
alors quelques exemples de
dysfonctionnement des délais de
traitement très long il ya des gens qui
se retrouvent sans assurance maladie
sans retraite des mois durant
un manque de lisibilité des double
prélèvement des cotisations déjà payé
réclamer des cotisations n'ont dû
réclamer des radiations erronée ça va
même jusqu'à la saisie de meubles il ya
des gens qui ont acquitté du rsi
supérieur au résultat et et il ya déjà
enfin quand vous interrogez vos
commerçants de de vauville de vos
villages de vos quartiers ils vous
disent mais on gagne rien on ne vit plus
notre travail ça c'est un drame absolu
alors nous avons par rapport à cela nous
ne sommes pas restés aux républicains
sans réaction puisque nous avons demandé
une mission parlementaire
elle nous a été refusé par sectarisme et
par idéologie
le président de l'assemblée nationale a
accepté une mission mais qui n'a été
confiée qu'à des députés socialistes ce
qui est contraire aux usages
démocratiques parce que ordinairement
l'émission on a un président et un
rapporteur qui sont généralement est
bien de sensibilité différente ça
équilibre les points de vue ça enrichit
la proche et c'est comme ça qu'on fait
de la bonne action politique
là non le sujet est tellement sensible
qui se le sont gardés pour l'instant on
a un petit rapport d'étape mais qui ne
nous laisse pas augurer tout de même de
solutions véritablement renversant alors
on a pris l'initiative au républicain on
a pris une initiative sous la conduite
de julien aubert dont j'ai parlé et de
bruno le maire
une mission parlementaire qui leur a été
refusée refusé eh bien on en a fait une
proposition de loi qui a été cosigné par
116 de nos collègues et qui propose
trois types de mesures à court moyen et
long terme
alors je ne vais pas vous en faire un
catalogue exhaustif mais la philosophie
la philosophie de ceux de cette ppl
c'est de protéger les indépendants il
faut les protéger de dispositions qui
pourraient mettre en péril leur activité
et mêmes mêmes leurs personnes et leurs
biens propres jeux peu importe ils sont
tombés
elles sont dans ma poche
pardon merci donc si mon cher alain donc
quelques quelques exemples de mesures
que nous préconisons dans cette ppl
je voudrais dire en préambule que dans
les propositions que nous serons amenés
à faire à l'issue de cette journée
dédiée au code du travail et à l'emploi
il faut que nous soyons très précis et
que nous ne nous trompions pas parce que
si nous devions proposer des mesures qui
ne résolvait pas les problèmes ou pire
qui en crée d'autres
vous imaginez bien l'effet que cela
produirait donc il faut que nous soyons
très ajustée sur ce que nous proposerons
en matière de résolution des problèmes
du rsi alors tout d'abord par exemple
nous voulons limiter l'appel à des
huissiers de justice uniquement pour le
recouvrement de cotisations de rsi au
seul cas ayant donné lieu à une décision
du tribunal
pas de saisies d'huissiers si le
tribunal ne s'est pas prononcé procédure
de conciliation préalable à tout envoi
une mise en demeure fonds
d'indemnisation des cotisants qui ont eu
à subir un préjudice lié à une erreur du
rsi liberté de choisir son régime
liberté de choisir son régime
aujourd'hui le récit est obligatoire et
toute la jurisprudence va dans ce sens
donc on ne peut pas échapper au récit
même quand il est défaillant donc
liberté de choix et possibilité de
revenir sur son choix
possibilité de mettre en oeuvre
l'autodéclaration et l'auto liquidation
des cotisations
l'absence de réponse du rsi équivaut à
un accord implicite de l'administration
on l'a évoqué tout à l'heure avec le
risque et la cour des comptes devra
certifier les comptes de ce régime parce
que ce que je ne vous ai pas dis c'est
que l'une des motivations de du
rassemblement des trois caisses était de
faire des économies on en attendait plus
de 12 % d'économies le coût de
fonctionnement du rsi a grimpé de 6%
donc il faut que nous puissions mesurer
les performances du régime et ensuite
nous voulons qu'il y ait une possibilité
d'étaler sur 36 mois le règlement des
cotisations
parce que s'il y a eu un problème quand
le chiffre d'affaires diminue
substantiellement il faut pouvoir étaler
les cotisations parce que tout
simplement les liquidités ne sont pas là
et on sait très bien que l'activité des
indépendants est fluctuante elle dépend
de la conjoncture elles dépendent tout
un tas de facteurs
voilà quelques propositions je ne les ai
pas toutes exposées mais je voudrais
vous dire que si nous étions restés aux
affaires il est bien évident que ce que
nous préconisons lan lorient mise en
oeuvre parce que on ne peut pas laisser
perdurer une situation comme celle là il
y va vraiment je dirais de notre
crédibilité politique d'une part mais
c'est presque pas le plus important
il y va vraiment de la survie de pan
essentiel de l'activité économique de
notre pays
je vous remercie